all right allison
allison where are you from version
where'd you grow up i am from south
florida i grew up in pompano beach which
is about an hour north of miami
tell me about your family
grew up in a good stable family had both
my parents and my two older brothers
my parents both worked nine to fives and
they were also very involved in the
church
we went to a baptist church that was in
our neighborhood and
my dad did music he was in the praise
band and my mom taught like an exercise
class there so between work and church
you know they had a lot of obligations
were very busy which made me very busy i
was you know always at the church or
doing some sort of extracurriculars
my brothers are 9 and 10 years older so
they weren't really forced to be
involved in church anymore at that point
they were really into skateboarding
and like fishing boating typical kind of
florida activities we actually had a
half pipe built in our backyard so they
always had friends over and
i was just like their biggest fans we
were really close even though i was you
know much younger i loved hanging out
with them and their friends
and like cracking jokes telling stories
i was kind of like a little comedian to
them and they were pretty good about
like letting me be around
um there was obviously typical like
sibling teasing but overall like they
were very kind to me and
you know like treated me like a friend
and everything was
was good um and stable and my parents
made sure we had everything that you
know we needed
and then up until uh
you know middle school is when things
started changing
my brothers had kind of already like
moved out sort of once they turned 18
but
were in and out and um
things started like disappearing in my
house laptops
gaming stations anything of value right
like my dad had really expensive
music recording equipment it started
disappearing and that's when it became
known that my oldest brother logan was
an addict and he was using
um
my parents found out because one of his
friends called my mom because they were
concerned about him
and
uh he was working at a bar at the time
and
his close friend and roommate was also
using oxys and introduced it to him
and i should note that in
2004 he was in a really bad car accident
he was 18
i was eight and uh he shattered both of
his ankles
had surgery with like metal plates and
screws so he had physical pain right but
he was never prescribed any real
painkillers like after that surgery he
was in a wheelchair did physical therapy
um
and was fine but yeah he still suffered
with pain when he was on his feet for
long hours
you know they would get really sore in
the cold weather they would get swollen
and luckily it doesn't get very cold in
florida but
you know there's still winter months and
so he was dealing with that pain
and you know working at that bar all
night long shifts you know his friend
was like try this that you know it'll
work for you and uh
it didn't and he was obviously dealing
with a lot of internal pain as well
but you would never know because he was
like
just one of those like nice cool popular
guys like tons of friends girlfriends
always smiling laughing like
you just looking at him you'd have no
idea he was very handsome like he had
you know everything kind of going for
him
when you say internal pain meaning what
low self-worth oh i see anxiety and
depression
but yeah like i said from the outside
you wouldn't know he looked like a guy
who you know had friends and and had a
positive life going for him you know um
he uh
he tried college but it didn't really
work out for him and so yeah he was
working at the bar
and uh slowly got addicted and uh
ended up moving back home and he was
pawning our things so that's you know
how we found out when all those items
started disappearing
because he needed money
and so my parents you know they tried
taking him to
different recovery centers and
he just couldn't stay clean you know
that's why i say i think it was
beyond just the physical pain i think it
was a lot of you know internalized pain
that i don't
know where it necessarily came from
but he definitely didn't like
communicate about it you know and this
is
you know mid mid 2000's mental health
wasn't really like talked about at that
time as far as you know his childhood
was similar to yours oh yeah you know he
didn't have any
any traumatic tragedies happen before
that you know most of all our family was
still alive at that point we have other
relatives who suffer with addiction i
have you know grandparents aunts cousins
so it's it's in the bloodline
somewhere you know i think that has
something to do with it that's always a
big factor i think yeah
um
but maybe there was more and maybe it
was just you know the way he he was born
i i'm not really sure but he was just
always a really nice sweet guy like
a mama's boy and in a good way you know
um
and so yeah my parents really tried to
get him clean and
i uh
i developed a lot of anger towards him
because i was just like sad that this
you know like
christian picture perfect family i
thought i had was you know
not not true
and i didn't have any friends going
through anything similar so i really
internalized what i was going through
and you know he got arrested the first
time for like stealing money out of an
open car
you know something like that
um
and then after that it was just he
couldn't stay clean you know so
probation it was just in and out of
different recovery centers halfway
houses
i remember i was in like seventh or
eighth grade
and a classmate was looking at mug shots
i don't know why and uh in florida it's
all public record so you can you can see
it all
and she came across someone with the
same last name as me and my last name's
not very common she's like is this your
brother i think i jokingly said like oh
no it's my cousin because my cousin was
like a troublemaker and stuff and uh
i just ran off to the bathroom crying
because i was none of my friends really
knew like i said like i was just
embarrassed and sad and
when he went away to jail
that first time i think
it was a month maybe two i'm not really
sure
he'd call and i just refused to talk to
him
because i was just mad
once he finally got out
i think
i saw him trying to get clean and that
kind of like pushed the anger away and i
started understanding a little bit more
but unfortunately at that same point my
other brother alex
he got into a car accident
nothing that required surgery but he did
have physical back pain
and he was prescribed oxies
and he very quickly became addicted this
is like 2009
so they were prescribing just an absurd
amount
he has since told me it was like
enough to overdose like 50 adults was
how much he was getting a month and he
was 21 years old like his back pain was
nowhere near that severe you know um
and this is at a time where the
pharmacies weren't really like tracking
refills so he was going to like five
doctors at a time just getting like
hundreds of oxies and xanax
but he was still like a functional
addict at this point he was working with
my dad he had a car
um
and him and logan weren't really getting
along at this point either
probably because they were just both
battling you know with with their
addictions
and he ended up getting arrested for
some theft as well because again needed
money um
my you know couldn't work with my dad
anymore my parents can't trust them
and now you know the pharmacies started
tracking everything so
he's now getting a lot less but his
tolerance has just skyrocketed uh so he
switched to heroin
a lot cheaper um
and began a battle with that
and in and out of jail halfway houses
you know for the next couple years so
now i'm in this cycle with both my
brothers and i'm kind of seeing like the
full spectrum
one brother getting it from a friend in
the street the other one getting it from
a doctor like and they both you know had
car accidents they had physical
needs for for pain relief but
it just it took over their lives
and i just started like working i got a
job at like 14 not that we needed the
money but i think i just wanted to be
busy not thinking about what was going
on i was really envious of a lot of my
friends
who had older siblings that you know
they could look up to and you know like
were doing things with their lives
but my anger for for both of them went
away very quickly because i was getting
older i was understanding addiction at a
different level
um
because like i said i had family members
with it but it was never present in my
household so i had you know some
knowledge but i didn't
see that it wasn't you know they didn't
go out looking for this by any means and
it just really took over their life like
like a true disease
so yeah i'm in high school and they're
in this cycle of in and out of jail
rehab centers
my parents ended up separating around
that time
i think just everything with
the boys was too much for them to handle
and
logan and
his girlfriend that he met who had a
one-year-old
not from him from a previous
relationship he really stepped in as
like that dad role
and it was really cool to see him
like in that space because he really
loved that little boy like like it was
his own son
um
but you know he was still struggling and
very quickly they moved in with me and
my mom
but you know that was not a long-term
solution so they decided they were going
to move to maine which is where his
girlfriend was from so that her family
could help
but he would need clearance from his
probation officer to go there and all of
that and i think he knew that that was
going to be a hurdle so he took the risk
and they just they moved i was really
bummed because it was like
right before my high school graduation
so this is 2014.
i really wanted him to be there
anyway they moved i went off to college
in orlando
and
a few months into being in maine logan
got pulled over for
something really you know license plate
missing or tail light something like
that but they saw he had a warrant for
his arrest
for fleeing the state of florida
so he got arrested they shipped him down
to miami
um
and
he got sentenced three years in prison
and i remember the day my mom
called me
after the hearing like i was in my
apartment of my college room and
when she said three years like i just
felt like
that was an absurd amount of time for
someone that i know is not a criminal
but is just suffering and like
you know i think my parents felt relief
knowing like well at least we know
he's gonna be safe for three years and
we don't have to live in this fear
that he's gonna die because i mean my
biggest fear growing up was getting a
call that one of my brothers overdosed
like
i didn't really have a lot of other
things that i was fearful of but that
because i just knew it was such a real
possibility like between the both of
them like and in south florida at this
time like it was really bad like there
was so many pill mills and and a lot of
people protesting and
i mean it's bad now everywhere but in
south florida at that point
it was really really bad like i said i
mean my brother's getting prescription
pills from five doctors like hundreds of
them for absolutely no reason um
so logan yeah he gets sentenced three
years
and he they sent him up to a men's
prison in northern florida like up by
the panhandle
and i visited him a few months
a few months to a year into him being
there with my mom and her new husband
and uh it was really good to see him he
was doing well he uh
was covered in tattoos he had a few
going in but uh not like how
how he how many he got um
but he was doing good and uh we talked
all the time i was always putting money
on his books and he'd call me and we
write letters and
like we stayed really close during those
years that he was in there
and then during that time i moved out
here to la
so he was like vicariously living you
know through me and
i was like pursuing a career in
entertainment
so i was working on like some really
cool projects with like movies and tv
and
i was i know i was making him proud
and that was important to me and during
that time i actually got this tattoo for
him which says your will is strong
because he had my flesh is weak my will
is strong so this was like a reminder to
him and to me that like you you know
you're gonna get through this time
and uh
he ended up getting released in january
of
2017.
i should back up just a bit that my
brother alex actually
got sober in 2016 um after his seventh
arrest
i think he did like maybe five months
and uh
i don't know he had a wake-up call
there wasn't really any one big thing i
think that did it but uh
i'm sure seeing your older brother go
away for a few years and just kind of
being over it he uh
he was able to get sober and really
focus on his music he's an artist he
goes by pause for a second
and
you know i think he's able to to deal
with it
because he can channel through his music
you know
so yeah logan gets out in january of
2017 and
him and alex are reunited for the first
time in
years i mean so he did the time but then
before that both of them were in and out
of jail that they really hadn't seen
each other this is the first time they
were both like
functional sober adults together
um
and they were doing good logan had a
goal of becoming a barber he wanted to
do hair
but he started working at a bar
which
none of us were really you know too
psyched about because that's not really
a good environment for a recovering
addict but it was people he knew it's
not easy to get a job after prison so
started working there
and
you know very quickly started using
again
i don't think i was aware that he was
using again because i was living out
here
but my mom knew and i think alex knew as
well
um and at that point like he was
functioning but but he was using and
they could tell because at this point i
mean it was just
we knew when he was and when he wasn't
and
june rolls around and i'm supposed to
graduate uh the fashion institute here
in downtown
walk
you know
staples center and my mom flew out and
her husband and they rented a house to
throw me a graduation party so it's a
couple nights before my graduation
and i'm at a concert with a couple
friends in inglewood my mom's in
huntington beach
visiting a friend before driving up here
and i get a call from my mom's husband
thought it was weird because they know
i'm at a concert
i ignore it they call me again i
immediately think okay so maybe
something's wrong but i'm thinking oh
like did my mom get in a car accident
because she was driving around like
buying
supplies and stuff and that's just like
where my my brain immediately went so i
stepped out in the hall and uh
my mom's husband i can tell he's crying
and he's like
logan overdosed
and there was a pause and
i think in that pause the part of me was
like okay does that mean like he's in
the hospital and he's gonna be okay
like i don't think i immediately jumped
to like
death and he's like and he died and
like i said i lived in fear my whole
life that i was gonna get that call
but now that he was out of prison and i
thought clean like that fear was gone
you know so it it just didn't feel real
that i was getting it now it didn't make
sense to me
i collapsed um
and
just i tried to go back to the concert
because i my logan loves music as well
he sang and played guitar and i was like
logan would want me to just stay at the
concert
and that's when like it really hit me
and i just i couldn't i go outside
and i called my mom
and i never cursed around my parents i
was like mom [ __ ] my graduation like
we need to get on the next flight home
we need to go home we need to be
together
um
and really the worst part is that my
brother alex is the one who found him
so what happened was logan didn't show
for work which is just not like him
so they called alex because they knew
him and i think he he instantly knew
something was wrong so he went to the
apartment that logan was staying at
and he found him i think he had to break
a window to get in or something
and like i hate that he has to live with
not only the grief of losing his brother
but
like that memory
obviously i've pictured what i think
that looks like but i don't know i've
never even been to that apartment i have
no idea that memory lives in his brain
and as a recovering addict himself i
mean
you would assume they would start using
again right and the fact that he has
stayed clean
like i don't think any of us give him
enough respect for
because he is
dealing with this on such a different
level than we are
even though it's deep for all of us you
know
but um
yeah he found him
with his girlfriend at the time
and then my dad showed up but it was too
late he was already gone
um it was cocaine laced with fentanyl
and he was one of ten people who died
that night within a two mile radius
so i mean it was obviously all got it
from the same
dealer the same source and uh
afterwards they had gone through his
phone and saw text messages between him
and whoever and
he knew that this was like some harder
stuff i don't know if he knew it was
exactly fentanyl
i know he didn't have a death wish by
any means but
i think maybe he thought like it's not
gonna happen to him just because it had
been so long you know that
he just didn't
he everyone's going to say this about
their love but he just didn't deserve it
you know he
he really never had a fair shot
at life as an adult
like i said he had his accident at 18
and from there it was just a vicious
cycle
um
and
yeah i mean a part of me died with him
part of my brother part of my parents
none of us have been the same since
um
but we're also we're all so much closer
now you know
and uh
you know it's uh the healing journey is
definitely not linear it uh
you know it forces you to
to look
death right in the face and it's you
know death is so taboo to talk about as
a society like we never really
you know communicate how to deal with it
when it is the only inevitable thing for
all of us um
and obviously when they're young and
it's a tragedy it's a whole nother level
but
i think if
i don't know my
my understanding and the way i look at
death now is very different
than when i was growing up in church and
and even beyond that because i was never
like
super super in
in a specific faith but um
i try not to look at death now as like
this permanent ending thing i i see it
now as a lot more of a transition
because i do feel him here
like his energy and his essence is
strong
and he's definitely with me all the time
giving me signs and my brother and my
mom they get signs all the time and uh
he pops up in my dreams from time to
time and uh they feel very real
because they're always like a normal
kind of thing but but it's almost like
homecoming-esque where
he's here with me and we acknowledge
that like he's back but we don't
acknowledge where he was
um so it's very interesting but but it
feels very real
and
you know some pretty big
opportunities and blessings have come to
me in the last couple years
that he definitely had to have like some
part of in like a spiritual way
i ended up becoming a personal assistant
for one of the biggest celebrities
who was one of logan's absolute favorite
artist and it's a job that found me
so i just feel like he had to have
something to do with that there's just
no way he didn't um
and then shortly after that i had my
daughter
which was the biggest blessing and i see
a lot of him in her
a lot
and i just hope that uh
you know i can
do him fair justice of
explaining to her how awesome
of a guy he was
and
that he was so much more than his
addiction
you know and i hope i can instill a lot
of knowledge in her about mental health
and addiction and
you know just about loving people
it's it's weird because i
love this version of myself the best i'm
i'm in the best place in my life
and it sucks that he's not here to see
it um
and just how i've evolved in like my
level of awareness and consciousness
there's so many conversations i wish
him and i could have had
because he was like a he was a really
great listener
and he really made you feel heard
and supported and
like my parents supported me coming to
la and following my dreams but
the support that i felt from my brother
felt very different like true belief
like he knew i could do this there's no
doubt in his mind
and
i don't think he felt like anyone had
his back in that way
[Music]
because your ability to
love yourself
improved
because of
oh yeah
um
love in general i in the way you instill
it in your daughter right exactly
the love and my understanding of love
now is
so much deeper
because it's really different to
love someone that is no longer here at
the level that i do
obviously i love my daughter
in an indescribable way and i i love my
partner and my family and everything
but the love that i have for logan now
that is still coming through like it's
still growing every day
like in these moments and in times that
i can keep his name alive and share his
story
it just it grows and grows and grows
and so i like i'm blessed in that i get
to feel this deeply
you know even though it came from like
such a tragedy
um
and if i can instill just an ounce of
that in my daughter you know and that
can be a ripple effect
you know to end these generational
curses then uh
then i'll be proud of that for sure
and um
yeah i mean i'm i'm blessed that my
brother alex is still here with us today
i'm blessed that he
um has been strong enough to never turn
back to opioids
and he is out here really really killing
it and living his best life right now
and the two of us are closer than ever
and everything we do
we do for logan
because one of the last things he told
alex and my mom
um was he was like i just want to shine
and it's like he always was he was
always shining but he could never see it
like i've never met anyone to ever say
anything bad about him
everyone
at his funeral and on all of his friends
like
we're truly mourning because he was a
very genuine person
and he really impacted a lot of people
in ways that
i hope somehow now
he can see and understand
i just wish he could have seen it then
you know
yeah he
he was a star
he still is a star i i feel his energy
here right now
like constantly i am
i'm feeling his presence i feel like
guidance that i get
is from him
i uh
i asked him for a sign not that long ago
i i asked him to show me some sort of
physical sign right i'm very into
spiritual metaphysical
uh
space and and i don't necessarily like
stick to one one truth um
and i asked him to show me a sign
in the form of a purple dolphin and i
wanted to be very specific
so that it wasn't something i see every
day and my brain would just be reaching
to you know think that was the sign so i
said i want to sign in the purple
dolphin
purple was his favorite color he loved
the water
and i didn't expect to like get a sign
quickly i know it can take
weeks months days i read a book called
signs which shared a lot of people who
who experienced signs from their loved
ones and
that same night i was scrolling netflix
and i saw a cover to a barbie movie with
three dolphins and one of them was a
purple dolphin and i had to like pause
for a second
and
be like
did he really already give me this sign
and i i almost felt like this energy of
like
really ali like you're asking me for a
sign like i thought we were past this
like you know like because i feel that
in tune with him still
um
i think he was showing me the sign to be
like all right come on
you know i'm here with you you know
so he's here
and um yeah he'll always be here but i
miss him every day and and that pain
it has subsided
i think now that i have a daughter like
i said like my my cup has has overflown
in that way but it's also made me
have a much
better understanding of what my parents
are going through having lost their
firstborn
because i there's no way i i could
understand that before i had a daughter
i thought the pain i'm feeling of losing
my brother is like as deep as it can get
and
you know once i had a child i was i
can't imagine
what what my mom and dad are feeling
um and they've never been the same since
but um
my family is strong
and we've gotten through it and we
continue to get through it
and like i said it's a it's a journey
and it'll it'll always be a journey
all right allison thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
i'm glad things are going off with you
now thank you me too
you